yeah I'm saying the best student it
should be the one who gets into school I
agree so again we go at the beginning of
this thing I said it's not racist and
now I'm thinking maybe it could be here
is the latest installment of change my
mind where we rationalize our positions
on controversial topics in our last
installment I sat down with Tina to
discuss affirmative action you can see
that by clicking a video here and in
this episode we continue in that vein
with three more conversations including
one with a UT and Princeton professor of
hip-hop remember to let me know what you
think about affirmative action in the
comments below and more importantly what
are your thoughts on these conversations
that transpired here alright enough talk
let's get to our first conversation meet
Ben Ben is it yes Steven nice to meet
you Ben do you mind scooching in a
little bit so I can now we don't have to
separate my shoulder reach now so I
don't know how familiar you are if at
all with what we do here with this
program especially taking providing an
opportunity to rationalize our positions
on seemingly controversial topics today
is affirmative action this was my
request here at UT I believe that
affirmative action is by definition
racist not a fan if you disagree with me
you're more than welcome to change my
mind well I think we in a perfect world
I don't think it should exist but we
don't live in a perfect world you know
we have marginalized these communities
we need help to bring them up you know
make them bring them up to the middle
class so that they can help you know the
other members of their community bring
them up and so that we can eliminate
this kind of poverty inequality that
usually ties with race so I think
affirmative action is a great way of
helping get rid of a so you said it's a
great way so it sounds to me like you've
said you believe that it's the right
thing to do and you believe it's an
effective way yes
why do you believe that it's been
effective well I mean I think those
communities those marginalized
communities are moving up through the
classes
and because they're getting these
college education 'z that they can get
because of affirmative action okay so
you believe that when you say
marginalized communities I want to be
clear do you mean asian-americans do you
mean simply black Americans because
they're obviously marginalized
communities who are very anti
affirmative action yes I mean like all
minority groups okay so how do you
believe that affirmative action for
example is effective in helping Asian
American students because they many of
them would disagree with you there's a
lawsuit against Harvard because of the
unfair standards applied to them that
are not applied equally to black
applicants well I think you know not all
of them feel that way I mean there are
some let me let me ask you this do you
think that it's fair for example when
the documents were revealed from Harvard
that on average an asian-american
student was required to get a 1350 in
the SATs versus a black student who was
only required to get an 1100 no I don't
think it's fair but again I think it's
not about being fair it's about bringing
these committees up because I mean the
African American community has been
marginalized more than the Asian
American community I would say okay so
it should be based on how much
marginalization yeah how do we first up
before we get to how effective
affirmative action is I guess how do we
rate that because no I'm a you know
Asian Americans were more recently put
in an internment camps and we had anti
Asian immigration is there nothing like
slavery okay like but it's far more
recent recent but slavery has a lot had
a lot more of a lasting effect I mean
okay internment camps you know they're
awful but the community bounce back from
that I mean more people went where
people came out of internment camps than
went in so it's not but slavery I mean
that is just scarring for an entire race
generationally like even three four five
oh eight generations removed as opposed
to internment camps yes so let me ask
you do you think it's right that for
example an Asian American female student
would have to score higher on the SATs
to be admitted in comparison to a white
male
student I don't think it's right but
again I just think that's what's got to
happen because we live in an imperfect
world okay so you think it's okay that
female Asian American students have to
do better than not only black students
but have to perform better than white
Americans and in other words Asian
students actually are unfairly treated
in comparison to white Americans so you
would have to argue I suppose that Asian
Americans have been less marginalized
than white males I haven't seen any
numbers that prove that yeah I mean if
you just look at the numbers for example
at Harvard and I can show them to you
afterward the average scores were
required to be admitted into higher
education Ivy League schools with Asian
Americans was 1350 with white Americans
it was 1310 with black Americans it was
1100 so an Asian American female student
would on average be required to have a
higher SAT score higher performative
metrics academically than a white male
that these are the consequences of
affirmative action again I haven't seen
those okay but let's assume that I'm not
lying okay
where would you light up on that just
kind of how it goes okay so forget about
the Asian Americans the Asian females
they can fend for themselves so we'll
get to black Americans so you believe
that affirmative action is a good thing
it's morally imperative I understand
that I disagree but you believe that
it's been effective for black Americans
and you said because now we see them
having more or less economic disparity
am i correct I'd like to hear you kind
of express your position why you believe
affirmative action is work well I think
it helps them get the education that
they need to do well you know in this
economy I mean because you gotta have
like a master's degree to get like
basically a minimum-wage job nowadays
and so I think it helps having that
especially when a lot of these schools
you know I mean UT itself has been like
you know targeting against African
American students I mean we have a
monument to Robert Ely
over there not especially something
really welcoming how have they been
targeting african-americans I'm not
familiar with that well there was a
whole article actually published about
how they use to test scores to target
african-american students how so I'm not
entirely familiar oh okay
well I'm not familiar either so I'd be
interested to hear that because that
sounds like it should be a national
scandal if the university is
specifically targeting black America it
was in the 60s after they were forced to
okay in the sixties and one not not
currently oh okay
good well it shouldn't you bring that up
you know there are fewer because you've
brought up the idea that more
african-americans are seemingly having
an better economic metrics I don't know
if have any data to back that up but
there are actually fewer black Americans
admitted to universities today than
there were thirty five years ago is that
percentage-wise or is that just numbers
as a percentage of the population in
total yeah fewer today than thirty five
years ago so it seemed that maybe
affirmative action hasn't encouraged
overall enrollment but what we have seen
is worse performative standards for
black Americans on campus you know and
these are these unintended consequences
a soft prejudice of low expectations for
example black Americans who get admitted
into a law program let's use Harvard law
as an example there are four times as
likely to fail to bar exam even though
they've gone to an Ivy League school and
logically I would argue that black
Americans being admitted solely on the
basis of race as you've advocated with
lower academic performance metrics end
up with a bar exam which is blind there
is no racial bias there with lower
academic performance metric outcomes and
there are more black Americans who drop
out 50% of black Americans on college
campus and higher education they make up
the bottom 10% respectively because
they're mismatched against peers who had
to be more qualified to get into the
university and that creates actually a
real a real problem and a higher dropout
rate and lower performance outcomes for
them could you see that as maybe an
outcome of unintended consequences for
affirmative action that might mean it's
not so effective
I guess I appreciate that I appreciate
you um being honest but you know what I
would like to see here's one thing I
want you to understand I would like to
see all Americans do better and I
certainly would like to see the outlook
economic outlook for African Americans
improve just as much I want to see it
improve for you or white Americans but I
don't believe that's necessarily
predicated on racially accepting people
to college on the basis of race a
because I think it's immoral to race
ously and implement college application
or acceptance policies be the best
indicator that we have or certainly the
the most determinative factor as far as
one's economic success academic success
where they end up prison has nothing to
do with a college degree do you know it
is do you know what the single greatest
socio-economic indicator of future
wealth employment graduating college is
but it's an experience you know having a
dual parent household having a mother
and a father who are still together do
you know that if you if you graduate
high school and you wait until you're
married to have kids there's a 98%
chance that you don't end up in poverty
over 70% make at least middle class or
higher the social mobility in this
country is unheard of for both black
Americans and white Americans now the
problem and we see this across all races
any time you deal with a single-parent
household and Barack Obama expressed
this as well beyond just research papers
the likelihood of ending up in prison is
exponentially higher the likelihood of
behavioral disorders the likelihood of
not making it through high schools
exponentially higher interestingly from
the 1960s where single-parent households
made up less than 25% of all black
households in 2019 they make up almost
80% with white holes household it's
below 30% that actually would explain
the economic disparity far more than the
idea of affirmative action or its
implementation therein
and uh but I'm not sure if that's the
only factor because I feel like there
are other factors that cause you know
people to separate to have single I
agree I agree
can I get present to my case as to why
that is it would be actually policies
very similar to affirmative action will
be policies like the model Cities
program under Lyndon Johnson the modern
welfare program as we know what these
were implemented in the 1960s that
encouraged and financially incentivize
people to be single-parent households
that's why you see such a strong family
household demographic for black
Americans the 1960s degrade to 80% our
fatherless household their singer parent
households there's an economic incentive
with the current welfare system to not
be married oh so I mean like because
it's how many checks you can collect if
you're married though you get tax breaks
like that you don't get it doesn't it
doesn't counterbalance the single
household benefits that you would get
from a welfare program the current
welfare program so and that's what's so
alarming to me about affirmative action
right because I understand in principle
the idea of model cities the idea of the
welfare implementation right I
understand there's this is right after
65 the Voting Rights Act and of course
you the Civil Rights Act in the 60s as
well I understand that they were trying
to right the wrongs of previous
generations but to way that the way to
right the wrong of previous generations
which involves the stomach
discrimination against blacks I think we
agree now involves systemic
discrimination against other people or
certainly systemic targeting of blacks
for specific programs right and so they
created the model Cities program they
created the modern welfare program which
incentivize single-parent household has
created more economic disparity than we
could have imagined and that is very
closely mirrored by affirmative action
it's trying to write the historical
wrongs of blacks not making up enough of
the campus fabric in the past by
implementing racist policies now and
it's having very much the same effects
of black students falling behind of
creating racial tension and unrest and
actually lowering overall performance
metrics so I would argue that it's not
only immoral because it's racist but
results wise just as welfare and the
model Cities program have had
detrimental effects in trying to right
the wrongs of the past
affirmative action has harmed black
Americans let alone Asian Americans in
trying to write the racial
discriminations of the past and that's
why I think we need to do away with it
so just if I may ask shorty you think we
should do to right the wrongs of the
past so I don't think you can right the
wrongs of the past I think what you can
do is set the best path moving forward
toward the future and we have seen
states that have basically done away
with affirmative action you know what's
interesting some minority enrollment has
gone up someone already enrollment has
gone down there's really no correlation
it's actually been relative relatively
evens out so firm ative action hasn't
had that much of an overall effect it
does seem as though it's had an overall
effect on there being fewer black
Americans on campus over the last 35
years I think we need to do away with it
and stop focusing on viewing everyone
through the prism of lens and view them
to the prison of intellectual diversity
and performative contributions I think
that would be fair to Asian Americans I
think it would be fair to black
Americans and I think it's the right
thing to do okay no fair yeah thank you
so much Ben no problem I appreciate it
and thank you for sitting down brother
no problem Thank You Man appreciate Dan
everybody and as always if you want
these videos to continue please do
consider joining mud club at louder with
Crider comm slash mug club at 69
annually for students veterans active
military you'd get this wonderful
quenette's mug and the full daily show
that is not available on youtube of
course we are not currently monetized so
it's the only way to ensure that this
content continues and of course bookmark
this channel check back for new videos
every single weekday 9:00 p.m. Eastern
okay
next conversation is with UT and
Princeton professor of hip hop Raphael
Steven what's name Raphael yeah I feel a
rasa Raphael Raphael
okay the Ninja Turtles
I liked Raphael as a kid because he had
a little bit of a little bit of spunk a
little bit of attitude he was alone it
was a wild man I appreciate it but my
favorite colors red as you can see this
was his why do I was red it was look
brand-new no no no you're not you're not
here stuff that you just keep them
looking good
dancing shoes okay well these they
certainly look better than my shoe so
dancing shoe suit but someone with
something you are a professor yeah I
teach dance oh wow and you teach that
here at UT yes okay here at U semester
okay well so you teach hip-hop or
improvisational approach to hip-hop at
UT yes after this do you think you could
maybe show me something I couldn't I
don't you know I'm very white I'm very
athletic but I'm a good I'm good at some
things but I think my mom says I'm a
good dancer so I'll give it a whirl okay
your mom tell you to pin the compliment
you all right so uh professor Rafael I
don't know how familiar you are at all
with what we do so it's basically an
opportunity to sit down and hopefully
have productive civil dialogues where we
rationalize our position on perceived
confrontational issues the idea is to
kind of disarm some some hot button
issues that people often yell about
rather than talk about and so today this
was my request actually from students at
UT as a topic of affirmative action
specifically as it relates to
applications and acceptance on college
campus
I believe that affirmative action as a
policy is by definition racist
I think it's wrong and I don't think
that it's worked but if you disagree
with me you're more than welcome to to
change my mind professor well initially
I was curious about what this whole
thing
I don't feel this racist and not having
as much information I'm sure as you do
without it to be able to let's just say
date that we have more being a black
professor you know more experience
yeah I'm my first my first thing is my
definition of affirmative action is is
to allocate resources to those who
underprivileged or have been
discriminated discriminated against from
the beginning okay
that's already a hint of racism right
discrimination against people of anyone
based on race is racism yeah it starts
with that yes so to even the playing
field you allow those those certain
resources so to speak to be distributed
people don't get them and I think
everybody across the board now gets a
fair chance
that's something there yeah so I don't
know that I agree with you in a sense
that um when I when I say racist I mean
if I definition I show this is amela
make sure so that you don't think I'm
being cute I don't necessarily mean
racially negative but racial prejudice
or discrimination right right
and so affirmative action in responding
I agree with you everything you just
said and responding to systemic racism
has now created a policy that is
systemically racist and that it
specifically either includes people
based on race or excludes people based
on race notably Asian Americans have
been disproportionately affected by
affirmative action negatively I'm sure
you're aware of the lawsuits that are
happening at Harvard so I understand
where you're coming from and I think
that it's a virtuous goal to want to
correct the wrongs of the past I don't
believe that the right way to do that is
to then implement more systemic
discrimination whether it's against
Asians white Americans Mexican black
Americans whatever it is and I also
would argue that it has not been
effective in achieving the results that
it wants so even if it's a virtuous goal
if we agreed that this idea of sort of
to use the term of someone whose earlier
reverse discrimination now against other
people with preferential treatment for
black Americans if we agree that that is
morally correct it still hasn't had net
positive results and in many ways it's
had net
negative results for black America I
can't agree with that and you can or
can't I can okay okay got a little bit
and I have to go back to some basic
run-of-the-mill statements two wrongs
don't make a right right right but at
the same time man there are because I
agree with what you said it has not made
a major difference right it only benefit
people a certain percentage of the
people which then own still leaves a
chunk of res people out so it's not it
doesn't it doesn't allow everybody right
that same kind of privilege so yeah
right what I wanted to say is say you
have someone who is someone brought this
up they have some kind of disability
right right like a physical disability
or mental disability yeah yeah and again
it let's go back some okay when I grew
up it was black and white that was it
right people causing something out of
your name
what people both like he was a lying
English racist now I don't think with
all of the things that are across the
board at this point all the different
groups it's no longer racist it's now
what I would call xenophobia people are
afraid of something different you
understand there's more than just that
everybody has a preference something
that they do not like it just so happens
to be that the human vision comes in
difficult cases rises and so they serve
some people not all people through them
I don't think you're afraid of me being
white and I'm not afraid of you being
black that hoping that's my character
right this is I'm not afraid right of
you right
but I've gone in places that created
tension where I am afraid to be in a
certain place right and not only because
of what I look like
sure but because I might present an
intimidating view right right and anyway
what's interesting is what you just
brought up is actually an argument that
people often make for racially
segregated schools because for example
we see that sex limited schools like
all-boys schools from all girls schools
they perform much better and the reason
for that is because they don't feel
uncomfortable either not even
necessarily being a minority for a long
time we assumed it was because black
people are a minority and they felt
uncomfortable and a lot of white people
but then we found out the same thing was
true even if you had a pretty mixed
student population and people sort of
being in an environment where they feel
as though they don't have to worry about
insensitivities offending people or this
sort of xenophobic and mindset as you
you've addressed generate more positive
outcomes and all boys are all girls
schools and so you have some racists who
say well then we should just have
segregated schools completely and I know
that that is not at all what you're
advocating it's not about what I'm
advocating it's just interesting that we
take something and I think we both agree
and say fear of anyone based on race is
bad you have racists say because it's
natural we need to implement segregation
and that's what we've seen historically
and I think this is in my opinion a soft
version of that is what we now know as
affirmative action because it is
excluding people based on race and and I
think that's wrong but you don't you
know me man it's hard to get the whole
idea about your definition of race out
of my head because I came up in the 70s
I only know one way understand sure so
we're talking someone who's let's just
say social political background or their
poverty level is different their
educational level is different right so
or school oh no no no no I'm sorry I'm
sorry there's a lot of things I want to
say can't get them all out but that's
okay we have time to get into a
university a prestigious university
let's just say here
Princeton sure they expect a certain
kind of student in place if you can't
deliver what the expectations of the
university the university is yeah it
doesn't work then right you you then I'm
not going to allow you in a mus move
because you don't have what it takes to
be here right regardless - in my issue
an affirmative action is it's the
opposite that's our cuz now they're
saying you don't have to what it takes
to get here
but because you're black we're going to
admit you even though an Asian kid
worked harder and got better scores
somewhere along the line someone said
there's not enough of a particular race
people here yeah now I again go back to
this thing I don't think it's racist but
I do agree with you
and what you said earlier
okay but well and you're not talking
about black and white that I'm talking
about okay so if you're not smart enough
to get into a certain place then nothing
is the affirmative action and that way
is only going to cause more problems
right on a larger scale not only the
people who want to get into schools not
not the parents of those people who want
to get into schools but when that gets
out you got a whole race of people or
old people people who are now and now
have a problem with that and they create
this possible it's not fair right what
it isn't and so no no I'm not talking
about sorry I'm a mister I'm saying I
thought you were saying like for example
of white students or Asian students are
saying well hey hold on a second I got
higher on the SATs and do more
extracurriculars it's not fair that it
went to a black guy and then make a big
fuss but I think the Asian kid makes a
fuss rightfully because it's tough right
now it's tough to get into a college as
an asian-american - what I'm saying if
this school if this school says you have
to have a certain criteria to get in
yeah what's the what's the problem with
that that's okay right that's best
what's supposed to be well I should
start saying that we now have somebody
got pissed off because they assume that
your
your that you had what it takes it takes
to get into school right right some
parents are mad now because they believe
that you belong in there and you just
may not so now this affirmative action
thing kicks in them well no I believe
the problem is before that so I would
like to go back to what you said before
and I agree with you I have no problem
of the school saying this is a set
criteria for you to meet to be eligible
for the school right I think we both
agree my problem is whether it's white
Asian or black when that criteria
includes and this race and that's what
affirmative action is affirmative action
isn't you need these test scores you
need these district curricular need this
essay it's you need all of these things
and you also need to be black and let's
add on top of it you also can have lower
scores if you're black because we expect
less of you right and I just had a girl
who sat down with me a girl named Tina
and this is just you know I can
privilege white guy but very sad rice
that she was saying well I think I've
benefited from affirmative action and
she listed everything that she did she
came from Longview went to a small
school didn't have a lot of AP programs
she did a lot of extracurriculars and
wrote an essay I said well that sounds
to me like you earned your spot here at
UT you worked really hard and she said
yeah I'd like to think so I said you'd
not think that you deserve to be here
she said well I think so but I also
think it could be because of affirmative
action and I said that's so sad it's so
sad that you can work so hard and
because other people maybe didn't work
so hard but got in really based on
tokenism you robbed that girl Tina of
her self-confidence in earning her
accomplishment so I agree with you that
university should have set out criteria
I just have a problem with that criteria
specifically involving race and I think
it's had negative results right so so
what about the
idea of just having more diversity into
the into the school onto the system
right that's another way to lose is
diversity make a diverse program we want
to make a diverse University where every
bit now doesn't look like just white
Asian you know that's you know everybody
now here also has access to get into
this into this place whether school job
or what Equal Opportunity with the same
thing in this sense no because I don't
have a problem with diversity occurring
naturally based on the premise of equal
opportunity it sounds to me like what
you're talking about is equal outcome
let me ask you so I clarified so I'm not
misunderstanding
when you say diversity what do you mean
specifically if you have if you have
your school 90% white and any only
people that can qualify to get into
schools or people of that background we
need to do something but that's not I
want to be clear that's not what
happened what's happened in front of
action is the Optronics plain some okay
turn out okay right so apologize if the
university is all white let's just leave
it at that make it simple university is
all white someone says something in the
system some some group says the schools
are white medium have more color in air
so the school implements some kind of
system that says let's reach out to the
trans community black community a
community right and then do that and
then so then the most Asians are scoring
or they are qualifying to be in that
place now the school's white Asian so
how do we get more Latinos and
diversity to the program so if your
target was people racial diversity
yeah if those people are not getting the
qualifications or the scores that it
takes to get into school then something
needs to be applied for that to happen
so the school meets the quota
affirmative action sets that up okay so
you support the idea of racial quotas to
promote racial diversity yeah but I
wouldn't call it I mean I mean I just
want to make sure because you just said
quota yeah yeah but I wouldn't call it
racial okay because so what would you
call specifically allowing a black
person in with lower credentials because
they're black if not racial what would
you call that all fan-man I would just
say it's offering an opportunity to
someone who would never have the chance
to do that kind of what they do the
chance by meeting the same criteria so
let me but let me kind of presenter you
they don't come from a place where
they're there if they grow up in an
environment that doesn't allow them
first of all to grow with an environment
to move into to be surrounded by the
thing that gives them a certain kind of
knowledge where they can they can learn
these things to get into the school yeah
we take tests sometimes come as a black
person in the in there in certain
schools where so a black person because
when I understand we take tests you
didn't do a Rachel Dolezal did you've
always been black so we take these tests
to get into a certain place if I fail
the test man I got to go back but how do
I learn but that's a sentiment of white
people how do them too how do people
learn to take testicles yes okay I'm
into to get into the place if it never
gonna happen and we need it's already
happening so let me let me address kind
of your point so you were saying a
school is entirely white okay first off
I disagree with your premise of
diversity for diversity's sake as a
virtue I don't think so I think that
intellectual diversity is more important
by the way that's much more lacking on
campus than racial diversity
intellectual diversity
as a matter of fact you have 40% of all
university campuses with not a single
Republican or conservative professor at
all 40%
you can't find 40% of any schools that
don't have a single black professor you
can't find probably 5% they don't have a
single black professor or a single
lesbian professor so intellectual
diversity is more importantly but to go
to that point you're assuming you're
presupposing that if a school is
entirely white which has never really
been the case by the way Matt in fact
black enrollment in higher tier
universities like Ivy League is lower
now than 35 years ago pre affirmative
action agreed so affirmative action is
had a negative effect on black
enrollment at higher education so I
don't agree with the premise that it's
all white by design
so I can't possibly agree with the next
premise which is we need to create X
percent quota of black people by design
I can't because it wasn't by design the
third majority white people just like
it's not by design that asian-americans
second who have disproportionately faced
discrimination and I don't want to
compare discrimination of black
Americans to asian-americans but
certainly internment camps and the
immigration policies against people from
China were very very severe I don't
believe that they should now be forced
to meet higher standards even though
they faced the same kind of descriptive
system of determination solely because
without any quotas they were
outperforming white people so an example
right now we talk about racial diversity
a white male can score lower so we all
go okay it should be okay for a black
person to score lower than Asian and get
into the same university that's what
people I don't agree with it but the
unintended consequences are an Asian
female right now has to score higher
than a white male solely because Asian
Americans have typically performed well
in standardized testing
they have done very well with
extracurriculars and you know the reason
for that they face discrimination they
faced extreme poverty and
first-generation immigrants they're very
strong nuclear family households and a
strong emphasis on that and this is
something we talked about before with
black Americans when you look at this
and you go okay why are there fewer
black enrollees right now in university
that top-tier universities and before
especially when you look at the fact
that a black female
with a higher education degree will
actually make more than a white so the
gap is closed in certain ways but the
disparity comes from Duke let me ask you
this do you know what the single biggest
socio-economic indicator is of it's not
even close Barack Obama said this every
set that we have reflects that the
biggest indicator we have of whether you
graduate high school whether you end up
in prison whether you go to a good
college whether you make a good living
whether you have healthy relationships
the dual parent households a mom and the
dad still actively engaged the household
black Americans in the 1960s had a 25%
single-parent household Reagan or
father's household Reagan today that's
nearly 80 compared to 25% with white
America 30% with white Americans and
much lower with Asian Americans and
Latin Americans that is a startling
trend and that will put black young men
at an extreme disadvantage and a lot of
you have to ask why and the reason why
was because of Lyndon Johnson sure you
remember this my dad's from Detroit as
well the model Cities program started in
Detroit and the welfare program which
incentivized single-parent households
and was marketed toward black people and
so you go from really strong family
structures in the black community much
more so than the white community for a
long time that's slowly degraded until
today and that's a more important
economic and social factor than even a
higher education degree and we're trying
to correct it with affirmative action at
university by the time the problems
already begun and we're trying to
correct it with affirmative action which
very much parallels the model cities in
the welfare program and that it's trying
to right the wrongs of the past with
systemic discrimination toward the
future of people of other races and
that's why I don't think that it's
morally correct and I would presuppose
that's why the results haven't yielded
what we thought affirmative action would
I'm gonna agree with it I don't I don't
think it did any justice but now I'm
starting to think more
I mean it could be it could be racist
what could be racist the formative
action yes but I thought you were saying
it could be racism pointing someone's
like now I'm gonna be a question there
that's what I was curious about it made
me come up be in the first place I
didn't think it was but putting these
things in place to what you're saying
both of them could stand yeah net side
by side it isn't it isn't depending on
how you look at it who are you what kind
of information do you have that could
that these things live and you can say
that both these things can stand side by
side and in comparison yeah yes or no
yay or nay yeah bad right real quick man
do you remember the study there was a
study in New York where the black white
asian kids went to the same school
wipe scored higher than asians was a
black for second so when asians no I'm
sorry whites blacks Asians yeah during
the summers over a four-year period the
Asians went to school and studied and
read more during the summers they were
first two years in was Asians blacks and
whites by the end of the 4-year period
it was Asian whites and blacks yeah
somewhere along the line something
changes and it could be the fact that no
one's pushing none of people are pushing
for the black kids to continue outside
of the institution fathers right it
could be but it's definitely I mean III
mean I don't
come from that I've come from a one
parent house and just a mom yeah and I
grew up quick I had my mom was working
11 7-eleven crazy that's a very
impressive and I'm sure you understand
your statistical anomaly because a lot
of black men who didn't have fathers
they didn't and they ended up in the
system so it's basically dead locked up
kids real bad off with friends who that
way to this day I only have up the
probably name about five not even then
three three cats I know who didn't go
this yeah right let me ask you this this
is a personal question how much compared
to because your professor successful
agent juicy teach at Princeton as well
or oppressed in and then you teach here
you tease okay so hit me on the fall and
Wow okay so very accomplished that's not
statistically very typical of by the way
not only black people but white people
without dad's white people Asian be
without dads across the board but let me
ask you this with how successful you are
and what you've seen mentioning your
friends you've ended up in prison which
is which is tragic it really is true and
I think there's a whole argument for
prison reform I'm actually very happy
what Donald Trump has done with
nonviolent drug offenders you know
letting some black people free which was
a big deal anyway sorry we'll get will
get back and I'm getting sidetracked now
how much of an advantage do you think it
would be compared to everything else
affirmative action welfare programs any
other government program that they've
created to try and help black Americans
would you agree that having a dad in
your household who supported you would
be a much greater factor in your ability
to thrive as a child than a government
program having a dad there who was there
for you and supported you how big of an
impact you think that would have made
I'm not sure man because the variables
are very different
unless you say there's no father's no
longer here but he also wasn't in my
life right if my father was in my life I
may not have I may not be sitting here
talking to you I could have taken the
route that he took whether he was in the
house or nothing mm-hmm there's also a
job you need to do it
Wow okay I'm assuming a good supportive
fathers what I'm saying if you had a
good supportive father who took care of
your mother and took care of you in the
house yeah how much of an advantage do
you think that would have been compared
to your friends and I will tell you
statistically that's an advantage and I
recognize this when we talk about
privilege as someone who is whether what
a Canadian a french-canadian immigrants
were natori to me when I look back and
go thank for me having a mother and a
father you made such a big impact and
when you look at the statistic across
all races it's consistent white kids
don't do well without a dad black kids
oh it's just that seventy-seven percent
of black households don't have a dad
right now right and the problem begins
long before they get to university and
so then we implement these effectively
racist racist measures in the university
and quotas to try and fix a problem that
was created by government programs in
the first place is my point you know
it's the the unintended consequence is
the ripple effect of creating a real
problem of economic disparity yeah and
now real quick what comes to mind when
you say that is earlier you said that
something was not by design if a
university yeah because if it was all
white yeah the only way I could agree
with your argument is if it was all
white only by design where they had a
policy instead of running a white James
okay now yeah what are you describing
right now if we go back and this is this
I can't even get into the I can't pull
from this stuff right now because my
head is all over the place with this I
didn't expect any of this but it when
you look at what was set up in in
the african-american communities at
certain time this is his 60s late 50s
60s 70s it was to disrupt the the homes
oh yeah the welfare programs and model
cities programs yeah you know what I
don't know I'm sorry I think some of
that was too many people make the
argument that Lyndon Johnson did it
deliberately yeah maybe you believe that
do it was that it was a design yeah it
was designed to set up things for what's
happening today right and there might
have been some programs that were put in
place or implemented to disrupt that but
here's the thing right it was presented
by Lyndon Johnson as a gift right it was
presented as though hey we're gonna fix
the problems in the past or we implement
welfare we're gonna do central organized
planning right right very similar to the
way affirmative action by design is
presented as a gift if something was not
looked at critically it becomes enabling
and that's what that was and so some
things that have put that are
implemented into systems are enabling
and affirmative action may just be that
thing we may have some kind of it
lingers man yeah right because I want
people especially I mean you so you what
was your path like becoming a professor
I'm super familiar with by the way okay
yeah my friends I sold drugs they've
been out of jail not me my mother was
very strong and so she I think she had
high expectations of me as a child I was
told to do things and expected them to
be done when she came home right that
carried with me all my life
and I watched my friends grow up in the
same one parent house or listen with
their mother when we got into the street
we did whatever we wanted to do and they
were at home and they took whatever they
had your street into the home I left
this [ __ ] outside because my mom was
going to do with my dad for to kick ass
yeah so I had something to had a
standard to live up to right
french-canadian mom's very similar in
that way my mom slap me around
not much in common with a lot of these
white Americans who get a timeout I was
like that's what you got French
Canadians yeah okay so I didn't go to
university I'm cutting some stuff out
but I didn't go to a university I had my
hands in the street and very many
different things that creating character
for me I learned what was right and
wrong and I learned how to decipher
between the two to get what I needed to
get to this is the people watching me
also I kind of stayed away from certain
things that I knew would get me in
trouble
yeah and if I think in trouble nobody
knew I was getting in trouble because
it's just a stream yeah yeah
don't have a college degree didn't go to
college so how do you become a professor
studied what I thought I was supposed to
study on my own I read a lot after I got
in school I read a lot was hungry for
information and I wasn't learning in
school this damn this stuff wasn't set
up for me in school it was a place for
me to go
worked by standard mm-hmm and get out
right what AM what am I supposed to do
live by what everybody else did go to
college get a head case young white kid
job the whole nine that didn't interest
me I wanted to make things I want that
was very creative and so that was the
same same way that said I was learning
disabled because I was bored oh man
same thing I was would talk to all the
damn time and wonder why people who
aren't I was in second grade reading on
the sixth grade level right when I
wanted to the second grade we were plus
two
we were bused out of the hood into into
the whites coops my dad was in Detroit
after the riots with the yeah that
worked like a charm didn't end the
integration busing system another
example of unintended consequences yeah
but now now with me as a child not
knowing where what I was doing where I
was going I took today as punishment for
talking too much I was put in the corner
to read as punishment for talking too
much after I read the books I was put in
the corner to write Chinese it's a hard
language to start Mandarin I don't
remember just any Chinese character so
you know why you're writing no it was
copied characters whatever he just had a
really racist professor at your writing
racist white Chinese justice crew right
was the one that was getting in trouble
all the time and I'm like you picking on
me right so I was telling
this woman doesn't like them that long
the long run a completely opposite
looking back it was you
this woman was creating tools punishment
that was encouraging creativity and
learning Oh turning destructive behavior
into productive ability yes I went back
I went to third grade back to the hood
school
whoo dude cutting class hanging out with
the wrong crowd the whole night right
and I remember that to this day that's
where I should have been because the
kind of person I was so anyway long
story short somewhere in in my head that
stuff stuck with me man and I lived but
I read things that I was interested in
all the time I continued to practice you
can ask you a quick question cuz I'm
interested you said so that happened
that teacher that was when you were
going across district and the new yes so
was that teacher what she wider was she
like so she was a old white woman know
who you thought was racist what do you
realized she was she was actually doing
things that encouraged me to be better
and then when you went back to the
schools where teachers were primarily
black know they were like - they didn't
take care of you know okay it's just
shuffling these kids through school to
get out right it's it despite the fact
that there's more spending in those
schools a lot of people don't know
there's more spending in the inner-city
schools it's just in men yeah so so what
did they do we got in trouble into those
schools put you in the room no book no
yeah you can't we just have to sit there
with your head down don't talk no
nothing let's destruct my teacher you
know what I have a similar story so they
it was in the fourth grade and I was do
you care about my story it's kind of its
kind of married marriage that's art
we've got enough and then we'll get back
to it but what happened was I was forced
cuz in French Canada you want to talk
about discrimination they actually
something called the language police
where if I open my name is Stephen if I
open Stevens diner apostrophe s I could
be fined and put in jail because the
French writing has to be two-and-a-half
times bigger than the English writing
even though Canada's an English country
but French is a sorry Quebec is a French
province it would be like Texas saying
there's a language police you have to
speak Spanish and you have to write all
your signs in Spanish
so not only that but if you have a
single parent born in Quebec you have to
go to French schooling so I do speak
French and English French is technically
my first language because I learned to
read and I learned to read and write at
first but I think in English and I've
lost a lot of my French so what happened
was in the third grade I felt so far
behind because I was doing math and
geography in history in French right and
in foreign language just because my mom
was French even though my dad was born
in Detroit yeah so because of some kind
of a loophole they finally got me to in
the middle of third grade no would have
been middle of fourth grade they got me
switched over I don't have to bleep the
name system from this year I think to
Missy
so she was an English teacher okay
French teacher was very nice if I said I
was learning disabled like borderline
[ __ ] got moved to an English class
were now I'm doing math in English and
this lady ms she was I want to say South
Indian really harsh really strict I did
not like her so I came from a nice
teacher who said he's learning disabled
they sent me to a teacher miss who a lot
of kids hated thought was mean but she
stayed after clients and taught me long
division as long as it took she didn't
do with a smile on her face but she
cared and she basically said your child
is not learning disabled actually she
said your child may have ADHD but she
said it's this is a language thing that
had happened and so it's just
interesting to me that you know it it
really does bridge that racial divide it
is about actually helping people and
wanting to better people regardless of
where they are regardless of their race
and that's my problem with affirmative
action on campus it's not blind like
your white professor was raised racially
blind and she was just helping a kid
miss was just helping a kid
affirmative action says don't help the
white kid I'll help the Asian kid you
have to help the black kid right and
that creates another system it also
perpetuates the idea that you have to
just do what you need to do right to
play the game write this as good as
everyone else so okay so I interrupt but
how did you become a professor of
hip-hop where you hip-hop dancer yeah
yeah I started breaking tonight anything
would break good and instead of breaking
in 1983 okay
you know it was very new at the time so
super long story short man I just
studied it and I performed in in theater
with the first hip hop dance company to
put hip hop dance on concert stage but
he has Philadelphia and from that point
on I found something that kept me
engaged all the time I can make music
and dance I can just set design I could
do all these things that appear on the
stage the same the canvas for me to do
what I had been learning in mr. Foggs
class right and so understanding that
from 1983 and studying it all the way up
to when I started Princeton 2014 I just
found myself in different places that
gave me an advantage it's gonna be a
weird start at Princeton like you know
what we need here at Princeton hip hop
mind-blowing yeah so they called me and
I said no a couple of times then
something is like dude you turned them
down I did white people's faces deal I
had what it took to be in Presley
growing up our president Harvard
Princeton Harvard Princeton Harvard Yale
right and now I'm here and even though
you know I'm a college degree
it was merit-based because of what
you've accomplished yet affectionately
so again that's still merit-based how
upsetting would it be to you for I would
imagine that in hip-hop right
specifically an eighties probably
largely black correct black and Latino
you know what if they came in and said
there are too many black hip-hop
professors we need to have more white
hip-hop professors okay and then you
said but that guy sucks well they're
like yeah but you know what there aren't
enough of them so we have lower
expectations because we know white
people can't dance but that doesn't even
have the
do it now what had happened was because
the schools have a service standard you
can't go in without degree you can't
answer that level of degree and so there
were a lot of people who have degrees I
could study or know someone that they
could bring in to teach what they needed
to teach right so there were white
people are people that didn't come from
the background who we're teaching those
those classes and then eventually I
guess the school is just felt like we
need to get some official some qualified
people in right in here to do what they
need to do and a couple of them over
anybody has has a couple honorary
degrees now from the University so he
doesn't have a degree either but he's
managed to do what it needs to what what
needed to be maybe it's different
because of the history of hip-hop at
Princeton but let's say when you were
touring yes it was mostly black and
Latino yeah it would probably piss you
off it would imagine if they just
started hiring white guys to diversify
who weren't good dancers you probably
would have said man that's not right
yeah because someone else who's a better
dancer is losing that spot true but if
you didn't do the work to get to that
point right it's on you saying if let's
say there were an audition okay let's
say you were there and it seems like you
high levels you probably retain on a lot
of auditions know that in a game okay
much but but but let's say your question
you're right yeah my people got more
gigs in the blacks yeah example because
there weren't it out to them no not even
it did just fit the bill now I would go
in I would go to a place that's it the
cast the casting call
hey would be the guy with a white beard
blue t-shirt red sneakers glasses the
pr6 exactly what I would be wearing
coincidentally yeah and the person who
got the job is completely opposite white
kid blue eyes blond hair
looks like we can put him anywhere we
need to him and so that is what becomes
the visual ID being being able to
identify hip-hop with that thing and
then you get that NSYNC that's what
happens yeah and it's still continuing
sure so but I think we were finding
common ground we both agree in that
instance the best dancer should be the
one who gets the job and I'm yeah you
know wasn't the case
yeah and I'm saying the best student
should be the one who gets into school I
agree so again we go at the beginning of
this thing with more information we put
both these things on the table and we
both there's no right or wrong it is how
can you prove rap which one you okay
well that's all we both have something
to think about
definitely man I have show me a little
bit hip-hop thank you okay well this is
the thing hold on was he's a professor
of hip-hop what I got to do so you go
like this go up and down and up and
everybody grab hands right we'll do like
this big wave yeah everyone grab and
let's do the wave everyone grab hands
come on now we're gonna do the wave
let's do a giant wing there you go
we'll start right here okay we grab
hands but okay you gotta connect
Johnny come here or Jeff I'll get my
security guy come on that's security
that will do that
all right he's missing okay look at this
how about that
look at this all different races genders
the power of dam that's called the
affirmative well thank you okay next up
[Music]
okay
okay forgive me if I don't I'll a yes
okay Stephen forgive me if I don't
pronounce it correctly so I grab a sip
of water before we start I'm very
thirsty on the cup yeah my mom is
french-canadian and she just doesn't
pronounce anything properly so I am
pronouncing floor she goes crossing and
you're like what I go Francine yeah just
put that on there so I understand so I
lay okay I'm close all right I don't
know how familiar you are if at all with
what we do with this program okay you
are so typically it's it's
and you allow this to finish me okay
that's it it's a chance to sort of
rationalize our positions on
controversial topics today by request at
UT is affirmative action I believe that
affirmative action is racist by
definition I think it's morally wrong
and it hasn't worked if you disagree
with me you're more than welcome to
change my mind well I mean I think that
calling it racist isn't like I guess the
correct term because it's like a policy
that was instituted in response to like
social inequalities experienced by
different like disadvantaged minorities
and disadvantaged operational groups I
just wanna make sure I agree with what
you just said but it's still racist by
definition okay I just want to make sure
we're you under because I understand
that what you're saying is racism
generally has a negative connotation and
I think that affirmative action has a
negative connotation because of its
results but I'm using this definition of
racism here racial prejudice or
discrimination by definition of
formative action is discriminating
against members of specific races based
on racial identity now they might be
doing it for what they believe to be an
altruistic reason which I understand you
agree with but by its definition it
still is exclusive based on race you see
I don't think that it like excused
raised from getting me accepted into at
the university sure it's awesome I mean
it can lower the pool of acceptance like
space that our university has because it
designates like a certain amount for
different races or you know but it
doesn't like exclusively sale or it
doesn't like kind of like if you're
applying to UT they're not just gonna
get the night because your wife no but I
could because I'm black so my point is
this when I'm sure you're aware of the
Harvard lawsuit but gosh we have clocks
we have planes going over a little bit
difficult so sorry if I get this really
close to your face right now for example
they look to accept people based on race
specifically black Americans and
Hispanics at the exclusion of Asian
Americans and white Americans
particularly Asian Americans so with the
same performance standards or even
better performance standards they will
exclude Asian Americans based on race as
you mentioned earlier how you said that
you don't think it's more than great I
don't I think that it's morally right to
kind of uplift some communities that are
socially disadvantaged throughout the
United States right
world or whatever okay um and this is
kind of a way to do that because people
that benefit from affirmative action
tend to graduate from college more than
people that don't benefit from it so it
helps like those people that are
educated and that are more knowledgeable
in like their area of study than other
people from their same race or ethnicity
that probably won't do as well because
they yeah empirically that's not the
case empirically there there are fewer
for example black Americans in
university than there were thirty five
years ago I mean in university well
that's that's across the board but there
are fewer enrollees and higher education
of black Americans and there were thirty
five years ago and actually their
graduation rates are lower and as
manufacturer performance centers once
they're in college is far lower for
black Americans for example like a black
American in law school right now is four
times more likely to fail the bar exam
than a white person that's not that
didn't use to be the case the different
disadvantages that they face when they
grow up so you believe that a black
American in 2019 faces more systemic
disadvantages than in 1969 because in
1969
it wasn't that they graduated more they
passed the exam more often I just think
that like even through history the way
that you know the laws and the policies
in the eighties having structured there
just hasn't been beneficial to African
Americans
like you right after they got out of
like slavery
up until now like up until now well no I
mean up until like contemporary America
like a few decades ago the whole civil
rights okay but I believe that things
have improved for african-americans like
systemically but they still are like
lagging in the race how so how do you
believe they've improved and how do you
believe they're they're lagging I guess
I mean because like how we talked about
graduation rates have increased in the
past like few decades but that's likely
haven't for blood well I'm confused by
what you mean forget zooming graduation
rates in university or even high school
because high school graduation rates
haven't they've declined well that's
also because of the economic
disadvantages that they face like public
schools in how like their schools okay
so like less funding yes exactly but
there's actually significantly higher
public funding to public schools in
urban areas for example like Detroit
where I was born right when my dad was
raised that lived in Michigan for a long
time the average per pupil spending in
Detroit schools is I think eighth in the
country at one point I was like top five
or you look at Washington DC in areas
that are primarily black they spend
significantly more per pupil in Detroit
about 14,000 right that's a lot more
than a national but certainly more than
white people but the graduation rate is
I think 20 something percent for black
Americans so the spending doesn't I
think it's not necessary about spending
okay so it's not economic that I want to
here yeah it's an economic problem but
not like that schools don't get enough I
guess because african-americans and
Hispanics tend to have different like
problems growing up financially at home
so they won't be as like ready to take
on like high school level courses as
like someone that's not experienced a if
they don't have to work when they're
like 1516 and why do you believe they
face considering that they're not facing
it at school they're not facing it
systemically but you're saying they're
facing economic disparity disadvantages
at home why do you think that is I think
it's just because of like how the like
structure of like races and ethnicities
is it's like wow I'm confused and I'm
just I'm trying to understand your
position because you kind of said like
well if you look at the economic
situation with schools we both agree
it's not an economic situation with
schools or public funding that's not the
case so you said it's at home so if it's
at home it's not structural why do you
believe that there are more economic
disadvantages to black Americans for
example at home because when like those
parents grew up and like when we got
that education beginning I guess succeed
at the same rate as like other places
like white people or yeah white people
end
asian-americans and all that so just
like in the past few years or in the
past few decades the trend has continued
and it's like in its bettering now but
it's I don't think that affirmative
action it's like racist or if it it's
you know what I'm like I don't know I
don't fully understand but I would I
would disagree with you and that the
trend has gotten worse since the 1960s I
think it has
I'm telling you empirically it has for
black Americans actually the economic
disadvantages have gotten worse for
black American children than black
American children in the 60s or 70s it's
worse today they get more funding
publicly they have affirmative action at
school yes all those things they get
more money through public funding 100%
we agree but at home personally they do
experience a disproportional amount of
economic disadvantages compared to white
families for Asian families I'm saying
they actually have more opportunities
economically they get more spending on
their schools they have more
applications that are accepted based on
affirmative action do you know why do
you know what the biggest the single
biggest socioeconomic determining factor
is in the country bar none according to
Pew Research according to Heritage
according to Barack Obama
what is if you could pick one thing that
would most significantly determine your
economic outlook your criminal outlook
your find out your your personal outlook
in relationships what do you think that
would be
was it single-parent households yes its
having two parents in the house I mean
yeah that also goes back to like I guess
different issues that don't I mean
single-parent households like that's I
guess individualistic what is
individualistic but why do you think
we've gone from the 1960s which sort of
you brought up right pre discrimination
and sort of the Voting Rights Act why do
you think black Americans went from only
a 25% single-parent household to nearly
80 percent today and that determines you
being more poor that determines you
ending up in prison that determines you
developing depression that determines
you having a successful marriage of your
own why do you think that not
individually statistically
overwhelmingly it went from only 25
percent father Lester single parent
households to nearly 80 and is not
reflected in Asian households or white
households isn't that important I mean
if we agree why do you think why I can
answer why it's happening but I want to
before before I ask would you let's say
you don't have the statistics okay but I
can offer them to you afterward would
you agree with the general premise that
the idea of having a nuclear family with
a mother and a father supporting
children is a huge influence and their
success in life and a huge advantage
okay and let's assume I'm not lying on
the statistics that black Americans have
gone from very strong nuclear families
to single parent or fatherless
households okay
so let's assume we both agree on that so
we both agree then that it would be
important to observe that problem and
say okay how can we reverse this trend
because that would do more than
affirmative action on campus or more
than public school funding we both agree
on that
okay so the reason why is because in the
60s as a way that you know the pendant
you've heard the sort of analogy the
pendulum swings both ways it was
discriminatory so to try and correct
previous discrimination they started
under Lyndon Johnson with the model
Cities program actually Detroit was
picked first because it was the
wealthiest city in the country in the
1950s so government programs centralized
urban planning started in 1960s and a
modern
pher program which incentivized and
encouraged single-parent households so
in trying to correct the systemic
oppression of the past they instated a
policy which I believe is racist by
definition to fix it moving forward
which led to unbelievably negative
economic outcomes and socio-economic
outcomes for black Americans and that is
mirrored very much by affirmative action
on campus to fix what happened before
let since to institute a racially
exclusive policy going forward my point
is that in the economy at large when you
look at the welfare modern welfare
program the model Cities program it
harmed black Americans at reparable II
for decades and affirmative action we're
seeing the ripples of it doing that
exact same thing I don't think
affirmative action cause I don't think
no I would say what caused the
single-parent household Urfa is is a
modern welfare system I don't think that
affirmative action is like never to
negatively affected black Americans or
Hispanic Americans because it's given
them more opportunities to go to get a
better education and get a better job so
just within that like there are
statistics that prove that people like I
get how I said earlier that benefit from
affirmative action to end up getting
higher paid higher paid jobs graduate
more and tend to do better then those
that did a benefit from no not really
economically and if it is I would say
that the statistics show it's negligible
and it's much much much smaller than had
we not implemented big government
programs that encourage fatherless and
single-parent households that's my
problem
that's my point is it mirrors the same
big government solutions to prior
discrimination on campus and it's only
ever had a net negative outcome and as
far as it having positive outcomes I was
just Achtung with Tina about this you'd
make more go into a trade school the
idea that a college degree is a
determining factor of your economic
status it's just not true today I mean
yes you know because it
you wanna be like a professional you
know you're gonna be a lawyer doctor you
need to go through the schooling to sure
people trade lawyer doctor sure but I do
agree that sometimes a college degree in
like specific areas doesn't really right
benefit someone so I want understand
your premise let's use lawyer as an
example
do you believe because that's actually a
very specific example I brought up
overall specifically with with black
Americans since we've been talking about
that fifty percent of black students
right now in higher education make up
the bottom twenty percent of class in
law fifty percent make up the bottom ten
percent a black student right now in the
United States is four times as likely to
fail the bar exam now that happens after
University right so they've already
gotten in the bar is not racist the
university isn't racist why do you think
they are failing the bar exam at certain
such an astronomical rate in comparison
to Asians and white Americans because
again how they grew up and how like
since they were raised compared to white
Americans and Asian Americans and that
doesn't like I don't think that because
they were a disadvantage then they
should not be given that like
affirmative action because then
affirmative action does help them kind
of but it doesn't sit at the end it
doesn't they fail the bar at four times
the rate of white students not you're
talking about like everything Americans
in general on college campus yeah yes
they perform very poorly on the
objective metrics afterward because
they're mismatched with Asian American
if you talk about black Americans that
benefit from the formative action yeah
it's a negligible it's negligible and it
is at the expense of other people so
that's where it goes to it being morally
correct
do you believe for example well sir can
I ask you do you believe that it's
morally correct that an Asian American
should have to get like an Asian female
right now applying to let's say Harvard
has to get a thirteen fifty on our SATs
to be accepted when a black student only
needs eleven hundred yeah well
do you think it's morally correct that a
black student or Hispanic student faces
like racial bias when taking the SAT
through like wording to the language
that is used I mean it's it's like both
a returned agent agent zone I mean let
me ask you this do you think that it's
fair that an asian-american woman has to
score higher on the SATs than a white
male because that's a consequence of
affirmative action well I mean if you
think you can't really like measure
fairness or because obviously like every
single side of like a political issue or
like just an issue in general is going
to favor one side or the other in some
way so there's gonna be like a pro and a
con to like each issue I guess not
always no no you see what's that's
interesting
say favor aside what does that mean by
definition favor favoritism it's it's
something it's favoritism it's I'm just
saying that like okay well then explain
for me cuz he's just in favor and I
wanted to explain why I disagree with
you so let's remove favor
you just said any policy will favor a
set so what did you mean to say I mean I
mean like any sorry it's cuz my friend
is like I just didn't like any like for
example okay I lost my Truffaut because
of it
so Asian you only give you some hot
coffee you can throw in your friends
face I know
so Asian Americans and whites I don't
think that they experienced the
disadvantage that like Hispanics and
black people experience like growing up
and you know through through their
childhood and up until like internment
camps Chinese immigration policy no
internment camps isn't like the same
thing as like but like the experience of
we should Latino Americans would have
Latin Latin American immigrants
experience that would be on par with
internment camps or bans on immigration
from China which we experience for a
very long time
what if Latin Americans experienced even
comparable to that I can't think of
anything
I mean I'm personally from Mexico and
it's like I had to come to nice
because of like the drug cartel violence
in so it's like yeah we don't missus
whoever nice to the experience don't be
like I guess you're in the US but no you
haven't but what I mean like so why
would it be our job to correct the
wrongs of your terrible corrupt
government in Mexico well it's not
correct
they're like wrongs it's to forgive like
I guess a fair chance for these people
like grew up disadvantaged we just
talked about fairness fairness is also
like trying to give everyone like an
equal opportunity yes that's equal
opportunity I am stressing equal
opportunity you were stressing equal
outcomes equal opportunity means we only
accept the people who perform the best
by metrics period I don't think his
growing up get equal opportunity as
compared to whites and asian-americans
really so you believe that that Latin
American what's latin-american cuz Latin
America is tell us a Latin American
Americans what's the term we should use
Mexican Americans Latin American
Americans you believe that they don't
that they face they have faced more
systemic discrimination in the United
States the nation Americans I mean
because I look at them and here's one
thing that's really important to me I
look at Asian Americans who are citizens
who were put in internment camps
wrongfully I look at Chinese immigrants
who wanted to migrate here legally and
could not for decades and I look at
Mexican Americans who come here
illegally and then are granted amnesty
and I see that as a much greater
advantage than an Asian American who is
not even one generation removed from an
internment camp or barred from migrating
to the country it doesn't seem to me
that's very fair I just think that
yes asian-americans don't face like you
said like as much systemic inequalities
then like that's your Hispanics because
even like whenever you want to get a job
or you're getting I don't know you wanna
like it and you want to interfere like a
physician within 10 seconds like if the
interviewer sees that like you're black
or you're expanding like they can have
this bias towards you and you know
believe that applies towards Asians I
think they actually have a positive
place okay well I can tell you where
they don't and applying to college you
know so you were talking about first off
potential anecdotal situations that you
believe and it's not supported by data
you believe that when interviewing for
job interviews Latin Americans or black
Americans might be viewed unfavorably
let me just do some yes or no real quick
I want to make sure I understand your
position here okay because I want to see
where we disagree it seems to me you
were saying that you believe when
applying for a job a black American or a
Latin American may face some personal
discrimination that an Asian American
wouldn't yes yes okay yes you believe
that okay there is no empirical evidence
to support that now let me respond with
I would present you an example where
Asian Americans absolutely do face
systemic observable discrimination on a
level not seen by black or Latin
Americans and that's when applying for
college it's not a maybe it's we know
that they're discriminated against I
mean that seems right I mean if I can't
really answer the eternal question
because you can't really like to explain
what you mean by like yes and no so okay
an Asian American right now can apply to
the exact same University to apply right
here they have to score higher on
standardized testing and they have to
have better performance more
extracurriculars than a black American
they will be discriminated against
because they are asian-american and they
have to work harder to get into college
well they're not being discriminated
against
the other like ethnicity group is giving
like it's not like again it's like UTSA
discriminating against whites or Asians
yes and Harvard is specifically that's
the lawsuit yes they are that's my point
yes they are I just don't I don't see it
as like discrimination towards them like
I don't I don't see it as like reverse
racism whatever I don't I didn't say
reverse racism I know but like it's
racism to say to an Asian you have to
get a 1350 on an SAT and then say to a
black person you only need an 1100
that's racism for me for me it's like
else can you understand why I see that
as racism and many asian-americans would
see it as racism I can see the point in
like maybe affirmative action needs
I guess improvement and like they need
to like a different kind of policy that
kind of benefits everybody and not just
like ethnic minorities that are
disadvantaged but that's interesting how
would you implement that like what kind
of a as opposed to affirmative action
now which is based on race it's
interesting let's explore that what do
you think would be the best way to do it
I think that we need to focus on like
how you're talking about
like all that going up I think that
education systems do a poor job of
educating kids even if I can public
schools you know teachers don't like
they need to realize that sometimes
those kids at home don't have value
systems moral systems implemented like
in there I guess at your household so
they need to be aware of that infant so
I want to make sure I understand you're
saying that black Americans and Latin
American Americans don't have values
instilled in them in their household no
no it's not that it's a-okay
how you were talking about single parent
household and how some like that's a big
determining factor of like economic
status all right well then that also can
Alterman however obviously how kids grow
up and whether they have like maybe a
sec I want to use at home or whether
they face like emotional like problems
and all of that like that needs to be
taken in account too so in other words
you would like to see a system or let's
say a white I consider some white white
trailer trash trailer park kid who
doesn't have a dad and has an abusive
mother who went to a really crappy
school in a rural area should be
admitted before a mexican-american
immigrant whose family is very wealthy I
don't think that they should be a minute
before I think that like public schools
need to change like their way of I guess
teaching especially like an elementary
school where like he's the mind of like
the child can be great or like change
like different ways that'd be you like
I'm asking about you saying changing
affirmative action you sounded like he
was talking about changing it to
socioeconomic status rather than race no
you still think it should be race I
don't think I think it should be like
something the more towards socioeconomic
status because that's because sometimes
affirmative action doesn't even benefit
like disadvantaged African Americans it
benefits people African Americans a core
disadvantage white Americans yeah
exactly more disadvantaged Asian
American so if we're talking about like
disadvantaged people in general I think
that affirmative action should shift
towards like the though not necessarily
like you said race but more towards
economic statuses right so we should
have lower standards for example for
let's say an Asian American or a white
American poor child from a single-parent
household than a wealthy Mexican
immigrant from a dual parent household
so you different socioeconomic status we
would give the preferential treatment to
the Asian or the white person in that
case I mean I would say so just because
they grew up in a disadvantaged way so
they won't have better education than
that way the wealthy person the Mexican
right okay so you believe we should
change affirmative action from
race-based to socio-economic base yes
okay and then we could look at fixing
socio-economic problems like doing away
with welfare completely so that we
actually start D incentivizing
single-parent households okay yeah I
know that I know a lot of a lot of Latin
American I see a Mexican American is
that allowed okay because YouTube is of
Mexican is a pejorative if we so I can
say Mexican American is not offensive
so because yeah I know yeah I know
Mexican American households place a
strong importance often on family values
and have big families and often have
mothers and fathers oh do you yeah
exactly do they all live in like the
same house like nine trucks in the
driveway they used to like my mom she's
she has like seven
and they all used to like live together
and like went because I'm like one of
the youngest cousins yeah but when she
had like my older brother that's a
thirtysomething and all those like they
also used to live together so all the
cars in the driveway and I'm there yeah
oh yeah I know their areas in Texas
roots like okay so this is clearly a
Mexican area because there's like 50
cars out in front of this house okay
well I understand that and I do
understand too that many Mexican
Americans who come here and want to work
hard yeah have a problem with the
welfare system as it exists and I think
we would find some common ground on that
because often many Mexican Americans
don't benefit from those same welfare
programs sometimes culturally because of
a sense of pride and they want to work
for it but they're also it could be
argued a correlation between that and
stronger family households with
mexican-american family immigrants and
that's why I think that maybe you see
for example yourself where your parents
first generation or you first-generation
Mexican immigrant me okay so you came
here so there is actually a statistic
it's kind of interesting that
mexican-american immigrants first
generation their children do better than
with black Americans immigrants or black
Americans sorry even born here then
their next generation does and again
that could largely be attributed to
strong families which a big part of that
is is you know that is what you kind of
go back to my point of like having those
single-parent households
increase from a 20% to 80 yeah in black
American households yeah and
mexican-americans like tend to put a
like focus on family value so I think
that's also white like personally I grew
up kind of very like driven kind of like
Institute parts in schools that kind of
not improve that has like teachers aware
of like different problems that these
kids new face yeah I'd like a general
way to like teach kids right not true
the problem that is that would be seen
as judgmental Ryan right now we can't
teach people that a mommy and a daddy
are the best way to raise children
because some people get offended even
though we know that would happen let me
ask you this when you list could you
mentioned affirmative action and I don't
know whether you have or haven't
benefited when you think of all of your
privileges in your life and I think of
all of my privilege and I don't mean the
sense of white privilege I just mean
privileges blessings when you think of
them can you think of anything that has
benefited you more in molding and
shaping who you are than having a mom
and a dad probably one of the biggest
determining factors so what I'm saying
is rather than viewing things for the
prism of race on campus after the
problem let's try and focus on that and
I think a lot better outcomes across the
board I think we disagree on some but I
think I'm glad that we could agree in
spirit on that yeah Thank You Ali thank
you so much appreciate it god bless
[Music]
hey there YouTube you if you like this
installment I've changed my mind click
on one of these other installments
playing in a box it's the only way you
can find it because if you search it it
may not show up because it's
controversial and YouTube wants to UM
discourage that the controversy to
change my mind playing by the rules we
just don't know what they are
subscribing to notifications